c'est l'heure du lunch au carrefour
familial hochelaga un organisme qui
offre de l'hébergement des cours et des
loisirs ou plus démunis les policiers
chez invitera n'est passé une journée
complète dans l'ensemble comme ça une
journée voit c'est quoi le vraiment sur
l'île de montréal selon centraide plus
de quatre cent mille personnes vivent
avec moins de 20 mille dollars par année
mais ce ne sont pas eux les plus ciblés
dans cette campagne nous avons annoncé
un nouveau mesures pour aider les
familles d'épargner pour les enfants
pour l'éducation
nous sommes les seuls à avoir un vrai
plan pour la classe moyenne
c'est clair que pour les deux parties
qui sont le plus susceptibles de
remporter la donne le 21 octobre c'est
la classe moyenne qui est au coeur de
nos préoccupations mais ça on est un peu
déconnectés du terrain c'est sûr que les
besoins sont grands
l'eau c'est sûr que dust ainsi la grosse
la grosse problématique c'est beaucoup
les logements dans le quartier hochelaga
maisonneuve seulement montréal 23 mille
ménages attendent d'avoir accès hlm
sylvie proulx dit avoir attendu le site
pendant 17 ans catastrophique
moi ça fait 5 h lun quartier et tout ce
que je vois qu est-ce qui sait
construire c'est plus des condos
d'autres choses comme vous je paye c'est
ça vient des loyers par mobile de verdi
j'obtiens juste qu'elle scinde elle a
longuement écouté pays traîtresse pas
grand chose les jeunes travaillent à qui
veulent enchaîner light social pour
tourner et de l'ail les ait passé son
non plus les logis ces personnes non ces
jeunes là le frapru reproche aux deux
grands partis de ne pas prioriser la
construction de logements sociaux est ce
côté des libéraux ça fait quand même 4 1
et quelques mois qu'on essaie de leur
répéter qu'il faut investir dans le
logement social on est déçu mais pas
encore d'annoncé probante là dessus les
conservateurs à certains désastres les
problèmes des gens peuvent exister
absolument pas en matière de logement
dans leur plateforme
selon le frapru c'est le bloc québécois
et le npd qui font la plus grande place
au logement social dans leur plateforme
le parti vert propose quant à lui un
revenu minimum garanti pour les plus
démunis
libéraux et conservateurs leur promet
plutôt des baisses d'impôts des mesures
intéressantes mais rien dans ce que
proposent les partis pour lutter
efficacement contre les inégalités
sociales
plus les organismes ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio canada montréal